hello welcome to this video this is
Round three coverage of this year's tata
steel tournament and one thing I have to
say right away that round was more
interesting than Ron too that's good
news the other thing I need to say is
that due to some commitment later I have
exactly let's say 55 minutes to record
this video nothing more nothing less
probably because it has it has some
content let's get going because of the
time issues ding Liren who you fun my
first game that I'm going to cover here
and that's probably the least exciting
of the bunch but still have a look would
you find goes for the Rogozin variation
in the Queens gambit pretty popular
nowadays see she's playing this for a
while now and with good results um the
line chosen here it's one of the one of
the yeah it's not one of the main lines
that would be wrong but one of the
current battle grounds that i discussed
in top-level chess III see 5 or sorry a
g5 first and now c5 yeah this is the way
like is some handling this can of
opening with very active play g5
breaking the pin c5 now queen 85 is
coming for counter play there was a
recent game between ganguly indian
player and you young g one of china's
top players he might be number two or
three in the rating list of china and
where d take see if i was played and
ding now when druke see one yeah Queen a
five but who you finally now the move 92
is the normal team here by ding yeah and
everything played pretty quickly so
probably they had this on there on the
radar yeah who you found out took on g3
after longer longer thing yeah she could
have taken on d2 and plays he form it
would have been a very sharp um game
coming from that something like this
black just snatching the pawn but it is
very dangerous something like this is
something that I wouldn't like to see as
black getting this thread in and well
this King looks a bit weird but
long-term blacks king will be in danger
because there's little porn cover
anywhere on the board yeah she didn't do
that she took on g3 I think this is all
so this is the farm war yeah circumspect
decision taking now here and Knight f6
and yeah they are still playing quite
quickly I think this is a position where
black pretty much has decided to get to
go to defend a slightly worse position
but something that is the vendor bull
it's not just downright awful she took
on c3 and now rook c8 to further
simplify there is an important point
here after the trade is that with that
pin white doesn't have an easy solution
to his King position white cannot just
castle here but you would like to do
probably and this is the thing how is
white going to get out of this
ultimately ding decided to put an end to
the pin with Queen B form and allow our
queen trade this end game of course if
we look at it must be a little bit
better for white because of blacks
weaknesses yeah this is a far more real
problem or age 685 then the white pole
and B form but it seems to be still okay
night be one now biting very logical
move going to see three however an
interesting line is given here by the
engine which is quite remarkable Knight
f3 attacking g5 and now black hand
defenders with King to d6 as 95 this
rookie yet no like wins apiece getting
out of the pin with a check so King f1
yeah is an idea at
and black is defending with this nice
move and then all of a sudden rook c8
threatening checkmate Knight f3 and here
black remarkably can take check trained
and go back to e8 shooting for either
I'm sorry for other be five or six to
get the default on back quite remarkable
quite remarkable line yeah shows how
resilient blacks position is in the game
not be one is played and they continued
form someone moves but black ultimately
um wasn't in any serious danger now
white always is a bit more active but he
had some trades down yeah and enter draw
so on the third drawer here form for who
you fall she's reading underdog in
almost all of the games and did a good
job so far not not even being into any
substantial trouble next game to check
his vessel a soul Sega Yaka Yaka d4 so
it's mostly not sure but I think most of
the time he plays efore but this
tournament is gone for d4 and c4 and
again here in general we we have not
seen a single pearl in defense cetera
hmm don't remember at least maybe like
one game or so our 14 but not that many
okay this is a Catalan opening and
kayaking plays the membership before
check slight surprise he normally plays
Bishop e7 and castles the difference is
that in this kind of position black is
normally not taking on see form as the
move Bishop Bishop t2 can provide a
useful extra move
compared to them um yeah to the move for
Bishop e7 without the check giving that
check actually shows blacks intention to
now keep the center not take on c4 but
keep it because in a position with c6
this is what black is doing the bishop
rather wants to be on c1 to fianchetto
on the two it is kind of can misplace is
a bit strong but it's not the best
possible square what why this doing
usually is to go for this go for Bishop
f4 based setup but this in comparison is
less desirable than fee and carrying
this piece yeah black went to Bishop as6
Bishop e7 is also move but Bishop a 6
it's the more a more active approach 95
looxcie 893 yeah very typical way to
proceed white is giving up upon that
temporarily but takes the center
cockiness keeping this and we see with
the time spent kayak indefinitely with
in preparation and so probably as well
they form a six and now d5 yeah this is
the most normal move ever but still as a
novelty well it's not a very frequently
discussed position but still a new move
default whatever is the most logical
move in the position because wyd wants
to open up break open the center and get
some room for his bishops in some cases
here also just wants to dislodge that c6
porn so that he might get something back
on the queenside with 8x b-58 XP 595 and
the whole game now gets very forcing we
see black taking wide recaptures nd5 and
we still see that kayaking is within his
preparation
move 17 but the moves leading up to this
are very logical yeah e5 Bishop is
attacked and went to g5 like deform and
white pretty much has to go d6 yeah I
mean white is a pawn down and he has to
yeah get something going if you play
some kind of retreat move black place
Queen B 6 and stops the d6 pawn to of
the d5 pawn to to go even further end
you really don't see any compensation
here and Saudi 6 yeah just use the
momentum um be takes c3 and Quincy
three-wide can take that Bishop later of
course yeah age 6 Bishop e3 back you
form a black it's still playing rather
quickly and now we're Dwight will said
to get this back okay the first move
okay I can throw a little bit longer now
we get an end game and in this end game
if we do a quick count black is a pawn
up but it's got two nights against two
bishops and also a six is weak and the
general of the initial assessment it's
probably too i immediately thought okay
well what should always get a pawn back
to to equalize the game it's hard to
believe that white can play for an edge
but he definitely should have enough
activity route d 6 plate taking a 6 what
black cannot do is just give up the a6
pawn for nothing so rupee 6 group d 1 an
n95 black is activating that night and
with bishop h3y it is now forcing that
trade it still looks kind of kind of
tricky and if the a6 pawn gets lost Luke
p8 however
attacking the pollen be too and now King
g2 was played why you can ask why yeah
if white takes on a six black is black
is taking taking this the idea is if I'm
sorry rupee a tiff kingi to root be too
there is Bishop deform so the pawn is
protected temporarily and it is black
smooth now thing is if black is now
playing something else then what you
played you still has to suffer what is
this what is this pawn all about if you
lose it for nothing not a good idea how
i can finds a good way to defend place
c3 freeing that c4 square so after
taking he goes night see for now a six
is dropping but black has a concrete and
strong counter plane take chantix 95
yeah this is how a good defense works
nowadays black had an extra porn but has
returned or has given up two points now
he's one born down but is active enough
now to clearly secure the draw not just
hanging around let's say passively in
some kind of position they want clarity
nowadays rather give up material for
active play f5 cannot be taken good
cause of check the fork c4 and now black
gets this activity that you wanted with
rook f8 and here get this back and can
easily draw this position now black is a
pawn down but there's absolutely nothing
that that can happen
black um has a very easy draw but just
staying on the sixth-ranked with the
rook and white of course has no way
forward you know if Y check goes for a
trade we get that this very typical draw
yeah MBLAQ I'm just running into the
corner and the h-bond cannot promote
they are not a super exciting game but a
very correct game both sides i think
played yeah play play close to perfectly
i think it was some very high quality
game just not very exciting for the
spectators will have something spectator
friendly later and let's go for the next
game when really thomashefsky and we had
a Queen's Indian yeah many d 4 games in
this tournament and queens in ian is
part of Tomashevsky avatar but
surprisingly he went form bishop to be
seven here which is I mean it's the most
normal looking with ever but in recent
years and no reason means like last 30
years shows that I'm getting really old
um recent years yeah since the 80s
Bishop a6 is the main move on attacking
the c forum pawn and quite often leading
to a little bit of more that's a dynamic
play then Bishop to d7 and Bishop e7
however has never been refuted or
anything it just not so common nowadays
Bishop g2 boo should be 793 castles ki
slight surprise yeah the common or most
common way to play it let's aim is to
whenever wide place 93 to get an ID form
and be ready to trade here no white
plays Bishop t2 or Quincy to it's the
normal way to play but thomashefsky
castles yet a probably a specific
in mind and this is allowing that d4 d5
push and something that a black has to
be very careful with that the five point
is really civilian striking the bishop
if you don't get any play against that
porn center and your life will be quite
difficult he immediately starts with
counter play Bishop before that's very
important you absolutely should not sit
there passively but sure before it's
increasing the pressure there and in
some cases black will just take on c3
from doubling of the pawns and playing
against the week queenside white castles
black tanks and planes 9 a-6 yeah what's
pawn structure looks pretty awful but on
the other hand he has more space and
some really good activity yeah here now
Bishop e3 was played also quite normal
looking attacking that night there on c5
and in some cases white um may just take
on c5 and play for look be one play on
the B file that Bishop sometimes on b7
is not in such lucky spot um yeah hitomi
chefs key played an interesting move and
seems like this is the novel team um and
it actually involves a foreign sacrifice
he plays the move these sinks on in some
master game would be eight was played
this is the somewhat more conservative
idea let's say with this rook covering
the bishop with d6 Tomashevsky actually
allows a little more sequence that
happens d takes is six and now yeah in
this position it's a bit tricky if black
recaptures here then of course Bishop e7
night
96 is very embarrassing so black cannot
recapture I can also not take with the
night as be 7s hanging so taken on g2
channel e takes f7 check root a skin g2
yeah what is that one set the porn
blunder from black no it wasn't
Tomashevsky I think willingly sacrifice
the spawn and this idea or this kind of
porn structure is quite funny quite a
quite a funny coincidence it's kind of
known from them from the Budapest gambit
there is a one particular line where
exactly the structure is happening one
difference to the Budapest is that in
the Budapest gambit usually white
retains the bishop payer a bit longer
here the bishops have been traded and
black claims compensation in the form of
those weak pawns and on yeah good active
pieces and light on c5 knight on f6 um
this black have enough compensation yeah
absolutely yeah I'm pretty sure about
that in fact I think the black position
is somewhat easier to play you you tried
Knight to g4 with just activating this
piece in some way going here possibly
looking at sea for we shouldn't forget
however that it also has a neat little
trick that is worth remembering if white
is playing some kind of lazy move not
paying any attention then it takes f 2
is very embarrassing yeah the idea is
that check the queen is in a big Fork so
y term should pay attention and he did
night f3 back yeah now this night comes
to before we see how active those nights
are and I think most of this year's is
rather logical
yeah why does keeping see form black as
maneuvering around a little bit and went
to a foyer with the Queen going for
green trade black doesn't mind to trade
queens even though is a pawn down on
with Queens off I think he feels like
any possible counter play against blacks
king I mean that doesn't look very
dangerous i have to admit but it's not
happening and the Queen was at least
defending a little bit you're helping so
traded 94 and black got the pawn back
white and really did not mind that so
much i think the double porn was never
in any big danger of promoting and it
didn't look like very essential to have
to see pawns so I think that white um
yeah I was okay with giving up on deck
we had a couple of more pretty normal
looking moose nothing nothing fancy or
that or needing explanations what
however and was a bit surprising is that
after look at 5pm Tomashevsky offered to
draw which was accepted and I don't
agree with that decision I find this a
bit weird because well okay it's I'm not
saying that he's like yeah very very
clearly better than when really but is
slightly the better player higher rated
and isn't this position kind of
comfortable for black you have to pawn
islands against two went two against
three I'm sorry yeah why does a and C
point isolated I'm not saying that black
is usually better i think it is just
maybe a little nibble but shouldn't you
play on I don't know if you give me this
position against someone like 100 points
lower then then I am I would continue
unless I really have something great to
do that evening yeah I don't know a bit
strange in my book why not play on a
little bit there was no particular
reason to draw this game okay anyway
was then very dom our chefs key um what
is the next game I have to really check
carefully to make it kind of with an
order of interest yeah okay I'm going
for four vehicles and a much-awaited
game it was some very often discussed
that first encounter between the Chinese
and yeah prodigy and the world champion
I was a bit surprised that this was such
an anticipated game I mean it's
happening at one point and it's still
not any kind of great competition I mean
Carlton is just clearly the stronger
player but still it's interesting to see
what happened we had a four in my book
surprising opening I mean this wasn't
surprising but he is an e-form player
but I was surprised that Carlton went
form the marshal attack that would be
one of the yeah would be pretty low on
my list of openings to suggest against
by it was a very good calculator and the
marshal attack mainline him has very
little strategic chess content it has
you mostly need to be excellently
prepared and be a great calculator there
are some end games maybe where you have
to assess correctly if you are porn down
if you draw comfortably or not but i
would rather expected a brayer or
something like that some kind of slowish
maneuvering game with many pieces on the
board i think in this kind of position
cardenas a heavy favorite against i even
though with black okay anyway sit
surprised that he went for some kind of
yeah very open position we had this line
here with d3 rookie one um i have to say
i'm not an expert on this opening
absolutely not Queen f3 and our queen
edge for playback ours are threatening
on h2 yes this
hanging on f5 but if white decides to
take a check he gets into huge trouble
him yeah white blocks if I for example
now night f4 is winning immediately yeah
it's it's it's very tactical but of
course they both know their way around
yeah g3 coming to h3 Bishop e3 yeah this
is the way it is normally played here by
white to speed up development white is
returning the d3 pawn and now white
catches up what why does shooting for
here in this line is normally a slight
very slight advantage and because of
better development I mean better
development is wrong but yeah you you
catch up and development and sometimes
black has three actresses threads d5 is
sometimes hanging with a porn lost
Bishop d5 CD queen takes and 94 is
coming and we'll see what happens in the
game queena finds a pretty typical thing
out of this opening I'm ship deform okay
8 kingi to yeah and here at this point
we got the first new move Queen takes f3
check by Carlton there was aged 6 in an
earlier game between while Sheila graph
and Micky Adams in bill 2015 um this is
a very normal looking move so king cakes
and now rookie 6 by karl is playing this
very quickly probably still being in
preparation why he was was thinking yeah
this kind of endgame I think is that is
quite right Luke c1 age six and King g2
yeah after some thought the move c4 here
was possible and looking very logical in
fact but it doesn't seem to lead to much
black and trade and defend with the cute
counter-attack here
yeah and an important point is said
after C takes see takes 90 for tanks
room shakes that black has got nothing
to fear here even if he loses that porn
he will draw very comfortably with
opposite colored bishops yeah this was
played by ye Ruby 64 possible night at
forum night before we see that whites
time sticking down a little bit check
maybe also influenced by the jack by the
situation it's not that easy to play
your first game against against the
world champion I assume I never had the
honor so I cannot really tell from
experience but those kind of first games
against the certain class of players
always a little bit tricky yeah I
remember first games again the grind
games against the Grandmaster and so on
it was kind of it's kind of a weird
situation yeah so here did pawn that
porn got lost um it is not that it was
blundered I think while you calculated
that this precisely he in general is a
very good calculator um black ian um
after rooty toot it has very little
chance of just keeping the pawn as some
whites pieces are so active now the
night years basically trapped that has
to go back somewhere here and then what
will get the porn back on as it happened
here up to six yeah white went around
here check and again it looks like black
should do something with the porn but
it'sit's ultimately very very
problematic that is hanging has to go
back to e7f for a white always has this
initiative and black cannot play
anything else here if you go somewhere
here then after route d7 you're even
worse and with this
and those pawns I'm sorry I made a six a
week so night see form and luke t seven
white has compensation for the pawn
bishop f6 that got traded and now rupee
ADA some is a precise move by carlson in
fact he manages to get some kind of
symbolic advantage him with the act of
rook however check it should never be
something that leads to a win for black
young hear you got ng5 blaggers a little
bit more active here so what has to be
careful it cannot play yeah any kind of
nonsense but he defended this precisely
kingi to King g7 age form yeah white
needs counter plane let's get yeah let's
get them apesar de form yeah and now
very important white I mean even though
that probably draw white can stick on
the FI keep that pawn but if you have
the alternative passive defense active
defense always go for active defense
Roxy three he gave up that pawn and put
his Luke on the sick Frank and this is a
very instructive way of defending the
rook is blocking the 6-ranked so the
black king cannot approach easily if the
black king tries to go over here to the
Queen side then the H pawn will start to
move so how is them yeah black supposed
to make any progress check he checked
and push the a porn forward and why does
just sit again come on chicks check
couple of chicks a three kings you 18
yet the game was drawn yeah there's
absolutely no way forward so that
defensive from formation held up nicely
okay if black does something like that
the issue is that there is also no way
forward yeah why does just stay on the a
file and if black starts to run then the
H porn would go and the rukon a one can
never move without dropping the pawn
there might be situations where um let's
get rid of couple of arrows there might
be situations where black it gets these
two points against the g3 pawn but this
is also still a dead wrong so a draw in
this game as I said I was a bit
surprised by the opening that was the
most surprising about the game I
wouldn't have a thought of the marshal
attack as the right right opening
against ye may be cards and was
expecting expecting an entire Marshall
that's certainly possible but if you
have the Martian in your repertoire and
you play against someone who's you're
happy with a draw then they will
probably get it yeah I mean this is kind
of line that why you chose es super safe
very difficult to lose with white okay
unless you really try hard to win it
then you can lose so um let's see what
games we have left and have to get get
some speed here otherwise it's getting
too late for me so um I'm going with
kawana Adams and to be honest I don't
understand the game I'm totally honest
there I don't understand this game at
all so let's see um let's look at a
couple of things we had an Enzo and
night and 3 p-6 III or kind of kind of
normal this has been seen form yeah it's
a totally normal line that same takes
takes 95 mad pg7 and f4 an interesting
approach by kara wanna maybe angling for
King side attack if black is not going
for quick counter play something like
week every age 3 comes to mind or
the same thing with the Queen Queen f3
f3 and black should get some counterplay
aunty he did see 592 maybe trying to
sideline that bishop to a five black
plate see form you should f5 and now g6
x by Adams yeah on a very strategically
imbalanced position type g6 I'm
according to my database is a novel team
even though we can be pretty sure that
this wasn't yeah this wasn't a core part
of preparation in this game an
interesting move now about caruana egos
screen to a 4 and we see that it took a
lot lot of time them and yeah it's kind
of interesting that is hanging and d7 is
also hanging so we will get a very
unusual paw information GTX and Queen
cakes mm-hmm it's a very strange
position black some structure looks weak
with a double death porn but he has a
fantastic square on e4 that cannot be
challenged at all while and whites
outpost clergy 5 can be challenged with
f6 this is a pretty big difference my
first impression you have to admit
what's that black should be totally fine
yeah you got potential three against two
here on the queenside and I couldn't
really see what what what point was with
this or this position what however has
to be said is that this is a pretty bad
bishop and whites bishop he is not
beautiful either but it has some ideas
to activate possibly over d2 before and
the game and I understood most of this
now have six why did not want to trade
and black found that d 7 is not a great
spot for the night here we would
c6 okay Bishop tutu King a jet-black
Lea's for the g file and kawana went 492
h for attacking f5 looking at one of
those weaknesses yeah then some curious
situation comes up a little bit later
here Adams chose to take with the rook
which i understand it looks like the
e-file is more of an acid and there was
no big hurry or need to take with this
pawn to kind of straighten the pawn
structure he could have done that but I
understand why he didn't that looks more
looks a little bit more dynamic this
move maybe we need one mucci a teenage
five I mean of that all that I kind of
get the rook is coming over white keeps
the Queen and I'll be four interesting
Luther white tries to do something on
the queenside if sorry after before have
black takes then white will get the porn
back yeah Adams didn't take you just
said okay this is a protected paso that
cannot be so bad 97 route 83 no just
most is I think trying to irritate black
a little bit with counter threats this
is not a not a big attack or anything um
yeah group G 493 back Bishop d7 all this
looks kind of normal threaded snatch g8
queen doesn't have any square so y plus
root g3 and yeah I mean around here
isn't black fine I can I can hardly
believe that he should have problems um
it seems that him he should have taken
on g3 this is probably giving black a
slight advantage room takes probably
King takes pawn takes be concern even
more and now something like this
is given by the engine the move c3 is
mostly possible because the king is
there but if white is taking with the
pawn you have to also yeah this is
always kind of its hanging over one's
head it's really really difficult
there's this kind of additional idea
it's like this sorry and age five and
the night is coming around here only
again only black can be better i think
that King takes is really stronger but
after c3 or this and then the NC three
black seems to be better this is really
bad and then with black entering the
position and bishops he wanders the
Queen c7c for I think black is fine here
and I think it always was fine it cannot
be a really bad position for black yeah
he played 98 queen age three so what I'm
what I'm pretty positive is that this
was an improvement but what I'm not sure
about is um a couple of things later we
should be seven maybe five you played a
five now and I wasn't sure is that
really necessary and does it help like
yeah um I mean I understand that white
was possibly shooting for a4 a5 um still
I don't know yeah why took and now white
got this grouping in and it helped like
it's more helpful for white um I don't
know every don't know it's it's a super
difficult strategic position um yeah h5
post plate kingi one king is going back
and night h6 hear the engine gives be 5
i'm trying to try to trade even more and
get rid of that be pointer paso y can go
a a five but then 97 see
is an idea this is what the engine gives
us better but I still felt like this
shouldn't be a big deal night h6 now you
have this this possibility sometimes um
yeah but now white play-doh regrouping
the rook was coming all the way over and
now that weakness is felled and this is
why I'm questioning a five but I'm not
one hundred percent sure if not playing
a five would have helped so this game is
a slight mystery to me have to really
say that I don't quite understand where
where exactly Adams drifted into a bad
position because now it is pretty bad
you know he is sitting on weaknesses
mostly and has a hard time to defend of
d5 d6 why justice activated while black
is basically sitting in the same kind of
situation he was some yeah couple of
Musa job yeah ultimately that God lost
and there is no dangerous counter play
why just took the age porn and now
continues to press on the queenside that
get lost we had a couple of more moves
but here Adams resigned a slightly
mysterious game for me I think there was
this one possibility sir Geneva Adams
could have got in a good position but it
somehow it wasn't clear to me how
exactly it drifted into that bad
situation yeah um I had to rush this a
little bit because the next two games
are really interesting so let's see um
what happened in those mamedyarov eliana
we had a semi Slav with a six very
decent line for black however this is an
interesting sideline with
95 takes energy form first impression is
isn't black just blundering the age 7
pawn hmm in fact not if white takes
check and goes to h eight then here if I
was hanging and black will get that back
because why does not have any m4 move
check because of the sound losing losing
the bishop so white shouldn't take he
went there for in this position
Mammadyarov did and now yeah black was
yeah black black had to answer this
question what to do about age 7 and it
seems that Bishop c5 what alien or plain
is fine counter-attacking that porn now
King it too yeah ticking is not a great
idea because now III is hang and Quincy
for threatened and why doesn't have an
answer to both threads so kini to
covering III and this seems to be an
absolutely critical moment early on in
this game where group d 8 was played by
iron off and it seems that after this
movie is in some trouble already um the
computers or in my case is a stock fish
and they suggest the really brutal move
not as their only movement the brutal
move f6 which is very hard to play for a
human player h7 is hanging with check
and some lines look downright crazy for
example the engine says that black is
okay in this position which is something
that I think no sane human being would
even contemplate a black is a piece down
age of seven saying was checked but he's
got enormous come to play with Queen g5
if the porn chicks and so on
and it's very tough I don't think that
Eleanor had this on the radar at all he
played rook the eighth I mean he can
also go g6 by the way does not he does
not have to play that crazy stuff but
you don't want to play a passive move
like g6 he played hope the eighth try to
again the sacrifice that and taking
wasn't that brilliant now it takes a
little bit too much time so Mammadyarov
played this he actually had a good
alternative here in night a for that he
did not go for that is an interesting
move the idea is that if black goes back
wide my paycheck and possibly shoot for
Bishop a five a very very weird kind of
situation with the rukon d 8 and 9 a-4
was interesting but he went age three
and black node took only three that was
the idea and no passive retreat giving
away a cell so this happened Chad with
deform black is getting the piece back
the problem is however that in this
position um why it is just better yeah
if black is now taking time to to cover
one of the pawns here let's say goes
g600 h6 doesn't really matter then
Queens III happens and how it's black
going to untangle his position why did
threatening c5 in here so let's say
black / c 5 then Bishop before and you
still you cannot develop this it's just
a pretty bad position alien off didn't
want to stick in this super passive
position so he decided to play here
check give the pawn and now shut down
the diagonal here with f5 it's clear
that blacks will opening went went
totally wrong yeah white has a great
position and it turns out that we go a
little bit
further ahead black could only hope for
a miracle there with a porn down and the
worst strontium he actually decided to
ditch the second porn for some kind of
activity yeah this move is not very much
liked by by any engine but I understand
the point the sea point is weak anyway
and you want to get your queen in for
some kind of some kind of play still
it's two ports and what should
definitely win the game so and all that
is I think pretty logical whites king is
going over to g3 later to h2 to be more
secure and what just has two pawns
nothing more nothing less yeah Queenie
for the black queen is attacking that
Luke on b1 and here a rupee 6 was a
pretty clean solution but remember jar
of went for Queen g5 attacking that rope
with check and now a n of when the rook
c8 it seems that he should have tried
Quint xbone even though the Queen
endgame here is probably losing now this
is what he tried and now the next move
came to a complete shock to to all of us
watching I happen to be a where it was a
circumstance to watch this again now I
think mamedyarov just confused to move
water he wanted to play rugby six and on
many replies the move c5 and what he
actually did is he had five minutes on
the clock by the way it was not like he
wasn't trying travel he played the move
c5 first and yes if you ask yourself
isn't that rook hanging it is that
happened and a lien of one so this very
early on is probably a heavy favorite
for the biggest blunder any top-level GM
game
I think member josh just had a complete
blackout he was thinking like rook b6
attacking this and yeah on I don't know
let's say black defense that porn you go
see five yeah he was simply playing the
second move first yeah and somehow
screwed up is his move on him yeah
tragic loss he had completely outplayed
early enough and it would have been a
very very deserved win ok so now then
the next and the last game and I'm a
little bit a little bit of a rush but
okay it is what it is we have a group
felt and the Russian variation and now a
six this is the current main line on the
on the top level and also what giving
normally plays um we see that both
players were playing quickly and they
certainly anticipated that this line
would happen yeah Black has given up a
pawn for the moment but he has good
chances to get c5 back and this is what
happened 94 txtx 95-year White has a
temporary activity he's got more active
pieces and black has to go back and now
f1 Queen to be seven and Bishop c5
attacking that rook this is an early
position in this game but a very
critical one here Aguirre played to move
rook e8 and he did so relatively quickly
it turns out that this is a pretty
serious mistake even though the reason
why this is a mistake is less than
obvious um rook e8 should have been
replaced madam of age 6 attacking that
night and after that white has actually
surprisingly on wide choice we can just
return but you can also try to set
files with very unclear play something
like that isn't isn't clear to me at all
at least what he could shoot for the
very weird looking move Knight 2h7 that
looks very strange yeah but yeah 90 f6
checkers is coming quite quite a funny
position how to assess but he had to
play a 6 h-6 rookie aid is now punished
with the amazing move f5 that navara
played relatively quickly probably
spotted the idea earlier yeah and what
is this all about the thing is after G
takes bishop age 5 black can resign just
like that f7 is double checked by night
and Bishop like this and black cannot
defend that porn with any kind of move
it just lost and this leads to a
disaster for the black king so we had to
take with the upon something that give
it it quickly because no alternative
again now BAM of course yeah the rook is
sacrificed takes nothing much else yeah
you cannot just allow Lou game 7 and
this is what would happen if black plays
this to defend this this cute move yeah
very nice very nice geometry and take
stakes and again f7 will fall with
disastrous consequences so he had to
take and now Bishop h5 white is a full
loop down but this threat is so enormous
black only has one move to continue that
game this is Bishop t5 he has to cover
that after which Navarro of course
played BAM the second look yeah okay you
get material back here this is very much
force and this position why it still is
if you counted them why does the piece
down for porn but of course the black
king is in grey
danger check King has to go to g6 check
check they were heated to this a little
bit Jack and now navara of course
deviated he played Queen f3 in this
position the move Bishop d4 was also
quite interesting intending e6 um I
think white is better with smooth but I
think he also was better in the game
here something that might happen is so
this knight c6 Kasich's check King takes
Bishop takes group d 8 a position like
that or rookie 7 I mean stuff tough to
say exactly maybe rukan seven white
definitely is better here he's get
gotten the piece back and with equal
material blacks king will be a constant
source of worry it is just very
uncomfortable to play why does
objectively clearly better and playing
this is murderous I guess for black what
he did create a 3 however it's also not
bad at all I think the real issue comes
a little bit later 97 check check Queen
f5 was possible but I think it's less
dangerous can something like this black
is quite happy that his king is safe and
black will get this pawn chess or the
check here check yeah and this is a key
moment actually it seems that he Aguirre
should have played Bishop to f6 which is
not the most natural whatever but it
gives some drawing chances on yeah it
gives drawing chance definitely some saw
some sounds a little bit too bad I think
black hairs chances to roll ready um
best line seems to be Bishop deform
against this if white is some is taking
here Rudy eight is you yes promising
nothing just like gets everything back
yeah so here and the move Bishop t4 is
the relatively relatively toughest and
now something like rookie
aight Teague's and 95 is what what
happens in a position like this check
check Queen age six white still can
continue this and is a little bit better
if he is winning it's very questionable
though the two rooks should be good to
defend um this is what gear we should
have gone for that Bishop f6 90 of 60
ever should lose the game let's see what
happens takes rook c8 Queen cakes yeah
it's already very very difficult for
black to defend this position normal
moves don't cut it very cute threatening
here and they broke checks than a 8
Hanks so this is why rocsi 8 was played
Queen takes root get back and now f7
check nice move check and takes on b5
white is two pawns up it doesn't look
good it doesn't look good at all the key
moment comes a little data we had a
couple of checks as repetitions to get
the time control done and here it's move
forward the notorious move 40 where
Navarro had to play a move and instead
of age for which probably would have won
instead of this is two pawns up yeah
with no particular compensation for
black he played the move Bishop t6 that
looks like a nice tactical idea as rook
t6 is failing due to Queen geez we check
but the problem is that Giri simply
could play simply play Bishop takes me
to just desperado in this bishop and it
turns out that this is just the position
with a pawn up where black has good
chances to get the a pawn to d by
doubling up on that a pond yeah this is
a tragedy
a little bit it was a great game played
by navara but he yeah he simply yeah
blundered in a way with that Bishop 36
move one more 40 of all moves yeah just
one move later and everything would have
been would have been fine in fact he'll
move 41 it was certainly very
disappointed he played Queen takes be
too it seems that Bishop f4 still gives
some practical chances here keeping the
bishop zone but yeah after this they
already agreed to a draw yeah black will
double up on the apron and win it so
yeah that was a bad end of the game
nearby for Navarro who played
excellently that f5 rook sacrifice on f5
taking on d5 what a fantastic what a
fantastic achievement but um ultimately
he didn't get the win in due to that
mistake on move 40 so I think it was
interesting round um and much more
interesting than round two we had a
couple of the size of games a huge
blunder by mamedyarov it should have
been a decisive game but in his favor
instead of that he blundered the whole
rook and we had kawana somewhat
mysterious wind against adam said at
least I couldn't really probably explain
to you properly maybe someone else can
but I had my problems to understand why
am Micky Adams all of a sudden got into
that huge trouble ok I hope you enjoyed
the video thanks for watching